these protesters came here today near
Alpher prison which is one of the
commercial chuck points that trucks use
to cross from Israel to the occupied
Palestinian territories
these Palestinians came here to say that
these trucks shouldn't come here and
they should work out Israeli products
and not use them to benefit the Israeli
economy they handed out letters to the
truck drivers urging them to stop
dealing with Israeli products they say
they came here today to push the
Palestinian leadership to endorse
boycott the Palestinian President
Mahmoud Abbas said he'll be looking into
pulling out of signed agreements with
Israel because the military we're
delivering messages calling upon
business people and agents of Israeli
products to stop these contracts and
businesses with Israel which is an
occupying state we want to be liberated
from the occupation Israeli army
dispersed the protests using tear gas
bombs and stun grenades to job well we
want the Palestinian Authority to impose
a ban against these products from
entering our markets and we want to see
these business people held accountable
so the Palestinian Authority has never
endorsed an official ban of Israeli
settlements Raley products only of
settlement products however we've heard
from the Palestinian Prime Minister
Mohamed esteya yesterday who said that
Palestinians who get permits to visit
Israel should not be thinking about
shopping there and should instead think
about endorsing the Palestinian economy